let's begin with matter why does it
matter hi I'm flute oh you're still a
planet in my heart Pluto
here's a question how much of your brain
do you actually use the Milky Way only
has about 10% of the force it needs to
hold itself together so what is holding
it together
undetectable particles we might just
have been wrong about how gravity works
this whole time what's happening now
let's take a look at the humble banana
see this tab here why is that there
seems almost a little too convenient
don't you think how much of your brain
actually make so you I think therefore I
add from so simple a beginning endless
forms most beautiful and most wonderful
have been and are being evolved fun
science fun science fun science it's a
sense of fun yeah science
you